thank you very much I thought being
asked to talk about
Nietzsche and style since style is
greatly related to this tendency to seem
seemingly contradict himself in
Nietzsche that I would focus on a line
from Zarathustra that in a way is
puzzling and certainly provocative the
line is thoughts that come on doves feet
guide the world now there's nothing too
strange in Nietzsche for about saying
that thoughts guide the world in fact
he's frequently contrasting men of
contemplation with those of action and
saying that although much of the world
takes action to be what's really
important in shaping the world people
who act are really following the
dictates of those who think and
contemplate because those who think and
contemplate are the ones that introduce
value and its value that drives action
but the idea of thoughts that come on
doves feet that I think is a little bit
less obvious it becomes even more
obvious when one notes the context which
is a scene in which Zarathustra is alone
with a voiceless voice namely something
within himself that keeps prodding him
to actually give voice to a thought that
he hasn't yet quite formulated and it's
clearly reluctant to do and this
voiceless voice or this stillest hour in
which he's completely by himself and
hears this inner voice keeps telling him
go ahead Zarathustra and what he says I
can't it will shatter me she says go
ahead and break she being the voiceless
voice which is female in German so the
question is what exactly does it mean
when this same voice says the thoughts
that come on doves feet guide the world
I think part of it has to do with the
whole experience of philosophy and
that's what I'm going to be arguing that
Nietzsche in his many stylistic antics
some of which just seem outrageous and
some of which seem to involve him
contradicting himself what he's really
doing is suggesting buy-in
juicing the experience of philosophizing
and from his point of view hopefully
philosophizing in such a way that
thoughts that come on dub feet actually
arise now actually the problem of style
and philosophy has been around in
Western thought certainly since Plato
and Plato very famously has Socrates in
the Republic comment that the poets lie
too much effectively he urges the
banishing of poets even homer on whom
Athenian education was largely based
from education because after all much in
Homer isn't literally true this
reinforces Plato's idea that truth is
really what philosophers are after and
the problem with poetry is that it too
often deviates from the truth one can
see this as related to rhetoric as a
whole the idea that one might want to
say things in a way that are appealing
to such an extent that one deviates from
really what the message is ideally the
message being truth Nietzsche is very
interested in this idea but he comes at
it from a different point of view his
view is that philosophers are themselves
poets here poet means something broader
than it does typically in English it
means something more like creative
makers and his suggestion is that
philosophy itself is a form of creative
making and if that's the case then
philosophers presenting themselves as
those who possess the absolute truth who
have come to this because of their
absolute commitment are deceiving maybe
themselves but certainly the rest of us
if that's what they claim they're doing
now Nietzsche obviously disagrees with
Plato but I think it's very interesting
that he uses Plato's notion of the lying
poet very often in his writing and I
think this is partly to underscore the
extent to which philosophers themselves
from his point of view are liars
that's more Liars than the rest of us
since he thinks all of us have to lie to
some extent so for example one place
where he makes I think it direct
allusion to Plato is engage science 92
where he points out it is noteworthy
that the great masters of prose have
almost always been poets - if not
publicly then at least secretly good
prose is written only face-to-face with
poetry for it it's an uninterrupted
well-mannered war with poetry all of its
attractions depend on the way in which
poetry is continually avoided and
contradicted and I think that is in some
ways endorsing Plato's idea that there
is a sense in which what one tries to do
as a prose writer presumably one who is
not engaging in fictions or creations
but telling the truth on some level is
trying to dodge the tendency to swerve
into something that is a little bit too
charming or too elegant or too engaging
and in doing so distorting the truth so
he thinks that's actually a sign of good
prose on the other hand well in some
ways agreeing again with Plato that
there's at least potentially a conflict
he has a character in Zarathustra called
the magician there in a certain poem be
described himself as having been mocked
as not a suitor of truth a philosopher
but instead only a fool only poet and
Nietzsche apparently thought this
important enough not simply to include
it in Zarathustra where you can say well
it's framed in such a way that who knows
what it means but he presents this also
as a poem in his own voice so it does
thing that he takes something to be
serious about what Plato says but on the
other hand also in Zarathustra he has
Zarathustra questioned by a disciple who
comes up to him and says you've said the
poet's lie too much what do you mean
and his comment basically is well yes
poets do lie too much we like to
much conceding that he though seemingly
a philosopher certainly a philosophical
teacher is in fact a poet and he claims
this is inevitable we all we also know
too little and were bad learners so we
simply have to lie he says but then he
adds another feature of this which is
one that I'm going to emphasize and in
effect he says we have to lie because
today isn't yesterday this is what he
says I am NOT one of those whom one may
ask about there why is my experience but
of yesterday it was long ago that I
experienced the reasons for my opinions
but what was it that Zarathustra once
said to you that the poet's lie too much
but Zarathustra too is a poet do you now
believe that he spoke the truth here why
do you believe that that kind of goes
back to exactly the sort of thing that
Paul was mentioning in the introduction
this often seems to be exactly
Nietzsche's pose
we frequently see him assert something
very enthusiastically and then say
something that it's very hard to square
it with what he just said what I'm going
to be arguing is that that from his
point of view as part of the experience
of philosophy but you can continue with
this theme of the the lying poets why is
it that lying is part of not only what
the poets do but what philosophers do
and what makes them therefore poets
Nietzsche's notion of power I think
plays an important role here now he's
very famous for having developed the
theory of the will to power he does this
in his later works but even before that
coinage is something that he is
presenting here there and everywhere
he's very concerned about power dynamics
in fact he analyzes and this is one of
the ways in which he's a brilliant
psychologist he analyzes so many things
that people treat as what they appear to
be in terms of people's justifications
and explanations of things as really
collisions of different efforts to
maintain or gain power within a
situation this notion of power has a
number of dimensions that I think
relevant to the whole issue of style one
of them is simply that he thinks all of
us are motivated by the desire for power
control ability to assert our own
influence in the situation and not be
controlled by it
and that of course as soon as other in
other human beings enter the picture is
going to involve interacting with them
and their own similar desire to control
the situation as much as possible as a
matter of fact we tend also to want to
think of ourselves in certain ways
because those ways are empowering so
there's a certain motivation for
deception
on two levels here already one is to
present things to other people in a way
that is going to maximize one's own
influence the second is to present
oneself to oneself in such a way as to
feel influential to actually think of
oneself as empowered because he
recognizes that one of the ways of being
confident and empowered in the world is
to just assume the pose so already
there's a tendency to incline toward
deception it's simply something he
thinks comes with any effort to interact
furthermore he sees power as something
that not only exert exists
interpersonally but inside the person as
well although he doesn't analyze human
psychology and detail that Freud does at
least not from the standpoint of trying
to identify specific drives and even
then Freud doesn't in collections
Nietzsche certainly thinks that we have
multiple drives and these multiple
drives inside ourselves are all vying
for dominance he certainly thinks that
much of what we do what motivates us
isn't really conscious to us and what in
fact is conscious to us tends to be
conscious to us in a way that is
consistent with the behest of some Drive
so whatever drive he thinks isn't is
most influential and I said any
and time is going to shake the way we
understand a situation consciousness in
other words follows the dictates of
drives which are largely unconscious
consciousness doesn't dictate to the
drives now this creates a problem if
what you want is the truth
because everything is going to be
presented even internally even before
you start thinking about trying to get
other people to agree with you or behave
in certain kinds of ways that maximize
your influence you're going to have
difficulty figuring out actually who it
is that is seeing things as they seem to
be at any given moment not who it is
whether it's someone else or you but who
are all these multiple parts of you that
are drives each seeking to control the
display so to speak and there we end up
having a real problem
so Nietzsche thinks there's no avoid
ability of lying if what you attempt to
do is present anything that you have to
say as the truth certainly we don't have
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth in fact we don't even have
the truth in that sense when we're alone
by ourselves trying to understand how it
is there's always going to be some part
of us that comes to the fore and
manipulates things in its direction and
other ways that we can see things drives
that we have that assume the background
but this is continually changing because
after all if we've got multiple drives
all of which are clamoring for
expression it typically is going to
happen that these drives end up at
different points taking over for each
other or basically removing one from
dominance and taking over dominance
themselves so a philosopher who poses as
a dogmatist
and this is the kind of philosopher that
Nietzsche's continually railing against
but in fact just about every philosopher
that he can think of I mean sometimes he
just says all philosophers are in fact
guilty of lying
this is what he says about them at one
point philosophers are all advocates who
resent that name and for the most part
even while he spokesman for their
prejudices which they baptize truths and
very far from having the courage of the
conscience that admits this precisely to
itself so philosophers in a sense are
something like double liars
they're liars like all of us are when we
think we have the truth because it's a
way of looking at the world that is
formulated by some drive within
ourselves and not something that
accurately reflects reality okay in that
sense you might say well if we all do it
in what sense does it even count to say
we're liars maybe it doesn't but the
second level is the problem that
Nietzsche seized with philosophers
philosophers see the truth as something
that philosophers claim to have they
claim to have some special purchase on
it when in fact they they don't they
can't they ought to be honest enough to
admit it and that's what they don't do
they themselves want the kind of
influence that comes with seeming to
possess the truth and therefore they are
liars
now obviously Nietzsche considers
himself a philosopher so one question is
what should we make of what he says
aren't you just like Zarathustra aren't
you another person that claims that the
poets are liars and you yourself are one
of them what do we make that I think
Nietzsche in general does think that
honesty is important in fact any time
you see him list virtues which
occasionally he does
honesty is definitely part of the list
and he frequently encourages
philosophers everyone should be more
honest with themselves so what does that
amount to if you're thinking about how a
philosopher could be more honest well
obviously one thing it has to include is
an acknowledgement that dogmatic poses
are simply that their poses that any
kind of dogmatism is not a reflection of
the
but in fact a kind of screen to avoid
people's awareness that you are an
advocate who resents the name and a more
honest philosopher would also
acknowledge their own variability so
even if it's a bit comic when
Zarathustra says well if I said that
yesterday who knows what why do you ask
me about that that's in some way it's
kind of silly but on the other hand
Nietzsche thinks what most of us are not
aware of is how much we end up changing
and how much our views changed just as a
virtue of our own changing in fact when
he attempts to clarify what he
understands philosophy to be he argues
as follows
a philosopher who has traversed many
kinds of Health and keeps traversing
them has passed through an equal number
of philosophies he simply cannot keep
from transposing his state every time
into the most spiritual form and
distance this art of Transfiguration is
philosophy now I think there are a
couple things to notice about that
passage one is that he thinks philosophy
is a Transfiguration of a state one is
in the other is that that state
continually changes and it changes along
with what he's calling states of health
now states of health how does that
relate to philosophy I think in a couple
of ways one we could view this as really
making the point that organic factors
have much more to do with our thought
than we are aware of and I think that is
one of Nietzsche's bold and really
important insights and he himself
suggests that one of the ways that he
came to this was just the experience he
had which most people would consider
completely unfortunate of being ill
thoroughly often he notices very clearly
that when he's in a state of starting to
convalesce from an illness the immune
system kicks in and he even describes
having been in that state as
intoxicating he described at one point
as feeling that he was attacked by hope
maybe showing how far gone things had
seen before that but the very fact that
changing from a state in which you are
really feeling decline and very likely
to feel a sense of conservatism with
respect to your energies is going to
have a very different effect on the way
you view the world what you understand
reality to be then the state when you're
suddenly feeling that energy is coming
go full tilt and suddenly you can really
take take on the world those sorts of
things are what he has to say about
typical examples of changes of states of
health but on the other hand given that
he thinks we're always in a kind of
dynamic condition with respect to the
environment changes of states of health
can be a lot more subtle than that and
frequently he does talk about ways in
which things like diet what one eats the
kind of environment one is in whether or
not one is in a room where the air is a
little closed all of these things have
an impact on the way we see things so
the physiological for him is something
very profound and certainly something
that militates toward recognizing that
our way of looking at the world is going
to change continually especially if
one's a philosopher I mean it's not
going to change more if one's a
philosopher but one needs to factor that
in if one is a philosopher I think given
that it's not surprising that he finds
style to be such a compelling way of
reflecting that in terms of philosophy
philosophical communication this is how
we define style to communicate a state
an inward tension of pathos by means of
signs including the tempo of these signs
that is the meaning of every style good
is any style that really communicates an
inward state that makes no mistake about
the signs the tempo of the signs the
gestures one thing I note in particular
about that passage is how much
musicality there seems to be in the way
he thinks about style he's talking
primarily since this is in a context of
describing his own writing of books
about written style but the idea of
communicating the tempo tensions often
those are the kinds of things that one
more associates with musical style and I
think that very much reflects his notion
that to really communicate
philosophically to communicate this
traversing of different states of health
in a way that is spiritual eyes that of
course is going to involve some
reflection of the way things change and
this is how I will eventually work my
way back to the thoughts that come on
doves feet but let's note some of the
things that Nietzsche does stylistically
that I think are somewhat on the macro
level or macro level but in specific
cases what I think he certainly tries to
do is effect effectively display his own
will to power by manipulating the reader
and manipulating the reader to have
certain kinds of states so the
communication of an inward state is what
style is about his approach to style is
to try to somehow get people to have
certain kinds of experiences and he does
this quite willfully one example and
this is just an example occurs in the
gay science which involves a lot of
discussion of the way in which one ought
to treat ideas lightly I think that
would be one way of glossing it that
even though one might conclude something
at a certain moment there are other ways
of looking at it and perspectivism the
idea that having different perspectives
on the world is valuable and in fact the
most truthful way one can possibly
reflect reality and reflect what what
the difference is between one person's
view and another one that's very
important they matically in the book
one of the things I think he tries to do
is get people to take on perspectives
that they don't sometimes have and here
is an example a kind of contentious
example Nietzsche at one point has a
number of passages about women and this
has not won him friends with some people
many of them seem a bit offensive
although I'm often surprised by that
because I don't find most of these as
offensive as he can be in other passages
but I think one of the things that's
very interesting about some of these
passages as he describes vignettes of
women about whom people tend to have
stereotypes and he describes them in
such a way that to make sense of the
passage you kind of have to take on
board what it would be like to look at
things from a woman in that
stereotypical positions point of view so
here's an example there are noble women
who were afflicted with a certain
poverty of the Spirit and they know no
better way to express their deepest
devotion than to offer their virtue and
shame they own nothing higher often this
present is accepted without establishing
as profound an obligation as the donors
had assumed a very melancholy story
certainly at sympathetic and I think in
our era it's maybe hard to fully grasp
the extent to which a fall and woman
would be a stereotype with whom few
people would have a great deal of
sympathy and I'm assuming that he thinks
most of his readers are heterosexual men
much of his at least the the tone in
which he refers to his brothers would
give one that impression and yet I think
in order to make sense of this passage
to see what he's saying one has to sort
of take on board this different
perspective of how someone in that
stereotypically ball and role actually
makes perfectly good sense to themselves
he's also analyzing what they do in
terms of power dynamics which fits
another theme that I've been pointing to
but I think that's a very interesting
strategy to take a larger example on the
genealogy
morals which is subtitled a polemic is a
very strange book I mean one on one
level it obviously a polemic it's
clearly a polemic against traditional
Christian slave morality as Nietzsche
understands it and it gives many
interesting accounts of how we could
have gotten where we are today and why
this is essentially unhealthy but I
think more subtly in terms of the style
what Nietzsche tries to do is almost
ensure that the reader is going to feel
contaminated it's not just that there's
something wrong with it but it's very
hard to read this without getting into
the position that Nietzsche thinks what
wants to say is the position of people
in Western civilization generally so the
first essay talks about slave morality
morality that is on the defensive that's
always looking to vindicate oneself by
means of making reference to other
people and seeing those other people in
a negative light in order to pull
oneself up he has a genealogical account
of where this came from even thinks that
initially for people who were
disempowered looking down on those who
were in a powerful position made it's
certainly a lot of sense and it's
motivated by the same thing that the
people in power were motivated by will
to power he's not trying to fault it in
a moralistic sense in that sense but he
is saying that it's unhealthy and it
uglify the world and it tends to make
interactions among people rather
poisoned what I think is very
interesting is the way he describes it
tends to put one on the defensive so
he's continually suggesting all of us
are contaminated by this and the reader
naturally says not I but is that not so
how do you even establish in your own
mind that it's not so probably by
looking around to see how other people
are doing it more than you are in other
words you're getting into the very frame
of mind that he is suggesting typifies
people in our tradition because
they've imbibed this kind of psychology
of slave morality second essay involves
discussion of bad conscience but it
begins with a discussion of aggressive
tendencies well actually a very it
begins at the very beginning with
talking about how cruelty has been used
in order to teach people how to keep
their promises and do the kind of things
that are considered to be moral in other
words we've instilled morality by means
of punishment and if one looks at
history pretty gruesome punishments at
that two things I think are going on
there one he's in a sense baiting or
sadism by going on at some length and
sighting others going on at some length
about the the glories of seeing someone
else suffer so one is likely to fall
into that and probably be a bit
uncomfortable about that if one doesn't
fall into that one still likely to feel
that even though one isn't a sadist
oneself ones virtue has been bought at a
terrible price so there's a kind of
guilt that one might feel over that and
since the force of the whole essay is to
suggest that we have this very strong
overpowering sense of guilt that again
developed in a very natural way on a
certain level that is it's not a bad
thing that humanity developed the
capacity for guilt but it's gotten out
of hand in some sense you might say is I
too quick a gloss on it but what's going
on
the fact that we're very likely to feel
guilt one way or another again puts us
in exactly the position that Nietzsche
wants us which is to recognize indeed I
do feel bad conscience third essay is an
essay in which he talks about the
aesthetic ideal the ideal of trying to
do without go without basically the
ideal of looking to another world
because one is sinful and this most of
what he has to say there is
indictment of priests as a
classification for those who lead the
religious institutions as those who have
given people a way of explaining why it
is that they feel or that that they feel
that something is wrong and someone
needs to be blamed
essentially Nietzsche says the
explanation for aesthetic ideals at
least historically as it's played out is
that people suffer they need to figure
out who's to blame for that and the
priest says you are and this is the way
that the whole doctrine of sinfulness
and suffering for sin plays out and it
makes sense and so people buy and accept
this that even though the medicine
Nietzsche thinks is very harsh medicine
indeed now in each is expecting his
readers if they've gotten to this point
or not people that are particularly
inclined to accept the medicine of the
ascetic priests so as soon as you say
well I don't believe that I'm a person
who believes in science the kind of
truths that we get empirically he
immediately points out that the
psychology is much the same as soon as
what you start doing is looking at how
it is that we go about finding the truth
what do we do we start sacrificing we
sacrifice what we want to think in favor
of what is true in other words he thinks
the whole psychology that drives those
who pursue knowledge is really not
different in type then the psychology
that drives the people that he thinks
are looking to somehow make sense of
their situation as sufferers by
accepting the medication offered by the
ascetic priest once again I think he's
gotten us exactly where he wants us
which is to feel like oh we're in
exactly the trap that you are describing
of course he says it's a polemic now
when gets to the end of the book and I
think a very reasonable question is well
what's the upshot of all this now we've
seen at least Nietzsche's
of how these various kinds of moral
phenomena have developed we probably by
this point feel ourselves implicated in
at least some of them where do we go
from here
and just to make sure that we score them
a little bit longer Anita has a preface
to the book that begins making fun of
people of knowledge who want one thing
more than anything else to take
something else home to have a little
nugget an upshot he doesn't give us one
he lets us just stew in her own juices
and points out that mean this final line
is we would rather we'll nothingness
than not will leaves it very much open
to us I think that's leaving it open to
us is actually a good way to segue into
what I think he does stylistically that
is more subtle even though I think this
is pretty subtle and this is something I
think that is endemic to the way he
writes he's consistently trying to
disturb what seems to be the flow of the
argument that he seems to be making and
this I think drives many people crazy
especially if they want a philosopher to
present us with a consistent case that
hangs together he will present an image
that really seems very compelling and
then pull a few planks out from under it
I mean that's that's something he does
seemingly without compunction and one
question is why would he do that I
certainly can't imagine that it's
because he's not aware of this I think
in fact it's very much to his purpose so
what is his purpose here I think what he
wants to do is suggest that philosophy
actually involves reconsideration more
than coming up with some nuggets of
truth to take home with us and it's the
reconsideration that I think he's trying
to force upon us in many of his writings
certainly he thinks that
self-deception that I mentioned before
that comes with an effort to think
philosophically is very difficult to
avoid entirely and one problem he sees
is just with the apparent stability of
words as soon as you try to formulate
something which certainly as a
philosopher one tries to do I mean even
if you're the honest philosopher he
looks for you're still going to try to
formulate an insight in words well that
in itself is a bit of a problem because
words tend to encapsulate in a way that
is not going to reflect this ongoing
change ability or alteration of the way
the world appears and appearance is
actually what we're left with and
Nietzsche's view the way the world
appears how to sum up what one sees the
big picture to be at any given point is
never going to be something that is as
clear definite and perpetual as our
words we'll often tend to suggest so he
makes the comment that I think maybe
sums up some of this whoever thinks
inwards thinks as an orator and not as a
thinker now what what I find especially
compelling about that passage is he's
not talking only about someone who's
thinking in words with the idea of
communicating to others though certainly
that's the case he's suggesting already
when you think in words you've already
assumed the position of someone who's
selling the case you might be selling
the case to yourself but you formulated
it and as soon as those formulas click
in you've got a bit of a problem
in fact in Zarathustra he has a couple
of very amusing vignettes well one could
see them as amusing what's amusing I
find is that he has this image of
Zarathustra in a love triangle with
wisdom and life and Zarathustra carries
on about how he loves his wisdom and
wisdom is so beautiful and so on and
life listens to this and says who are
you talking about certainly of me but
you shouldn't be saying things like that
my face in other words I think what the
suggestion here is Zarathustra and Tsar
theater says no I was talking about my
wisdom but is it my fault that I get the
two confused they look so much alike I
think he's saying well my wisdom that's
the formulations
it's how I try to love life I'm a
thinker after all and one of these
contemplative types I try to use words
and capture but what I try to capture
what can't be captured and frequently in
each his writings he talks about having
tried to get these wicked insights he
had or these bold ideas into words and
they look so pale by comparison that
sort of thing I think he thinks is
inevitable but there's also the sense
that in thinking philosophically what he
sees as most important is to resist the
effort to try to pin it down as soon as
you're pinning it down you've lost it
and so he stresses the way in which
truth reveals itself only once he talks
about truth being veiled and the veil if
if it's removed at all is removed Bree
away it was removed briefly not
something that you can just look at and
refer to again over and over and I think
this idea of veiling gets at what at the
idea of always being on the alert to
what's behind whatever the immediately
attractive formulation is in Beyond Good
and Evil he suggests this the hermit
will doubt whether a philosopher could
possibly have ultimate and real opinions
whether behind every one of his caves
there is not must not be another deeper
cave every judgment is a foreground
judgment that is a hermits judgment
every philosophy also conceals a
philosophy every opinion is also a
hideout every word also a mask now
actually he's assumed a mask himself
there because he's talking in
in the words of a hermit who presumably
isn't talking to anybody besides himself
and he's Nietzsche is actually writing
this to us but I think he points to the
position of a hermit to make a point to
that if you take seriously what he says
about the order as soon as you start
trying to defend a position where your
philosophical formulation comes with the
idea of defending it or presenting it or
compelling others to it then your agenda
is very different from simply trying to
have insight or to be able to recognize
something to see the moment when truth
is unveiled and so he encourages
solitude for the thinker in order to
avoid all those kind of things
but at the same time even that solitude
is never enough simply to say oh well
now I've got it because what happens in
solitude particularly slow solitude
solitude that allows for reflection or
contemplation it's not that one stays
with a certain point in fact the
thoughts that come on doves feet and I
think this is what he has in mind are
those thoughts that arise after you
allow a certain insight to have its
moment for you if you think any further
it's often thinking well but on the
other hand or yes but we shouldn't
forget in fact these are the kinds of
things that Nietzsche himself uses as
segues very often and I think that's how
he tries to induce something of this
frame of mind for us he also speaks of
trying to slow us down so at one point
he comments perhaps on a philologist
still that is to say a teacher of slow
reading in this end I also write slowly
nowadays it is not only my habit it is
also to my taste a malicious taste
perhaps no longer to write anything
which does not reduce to despair every
sort of man who is
in a hurry so I think what he is
deliberately trying to do is slow the
reader down and create so many
impediments to just taking some idea he
has and running with it precisely
because he himself objects or qualifies
or steers the discussion into a slightly
different angle on things so that what
he's trying to do is give us the
experience of philosophy in which
thoughts that come on doves feet can
actually arise for us and so his double
takes his superficial contradictions his
tendency to have some displacing
realization happen I think all of these
have to do with his notion that we never
have done with it if we're thinkers and
as thinkers we shouldn't have done with
it and the honest philosopher is going
to be one who doesn't ever attempt to
have done with it
so from that point of view what he
thinks philosophy shouldn't be is a
defense of entrenched positions
maintaining one's case instead I think
he thinks if one finds yourself doing
that time to go by your get by yourself
slow down and allow thought to actually
happen at one point he says a thought
happens when it will not win I will and
I think that's exactly what he is
getting at when he talks about thoughts
that come on dubs feet now of course he
has his own thoughts he has lots of
opinions and some people might read
Nietzsche as a man of so many opinions
it's hard to imagine that what he's
really trying to do is get us to subvert
them but I think that even that is a way
of provoking our experience of
philosophy if only by getting us to
challenge what he says that maybe starts
the possibility of having our own
realizations and I think this art of
realizing and then thinking again is
exactly what he thinks philosophy is and
what his writings cause
to experience thanks
oh absolutely I oh I I think the idea
isn't something that just kind of I
think he's thinking of a dove like
dropping from the sky but very quietly
it just you know sudden suddenly it
appears the dove has arrived but we have
to be very calm in order to allow yes
because it comes on doves feet yeah yeah
yeah well he's happy with Christian
images
oh yes right yeah well I certainly think
he thinks I mean there is a truth
concept that he has in that he's talking
about honesty so I think that does make
reference to some kind of truth concept
but the question is what kind it are is
one being honest to the way things
appear to one or does one have some
subterfuge behind it that would be I
mean the truth of the way things appear
to one if you will but that isn't gonna
be the whole truth but then I think he
also thinks that there's a sense in
which a lot of this collapses if you
think you can't that human beings don't
have access to the whole truth then and
what I mean if you're going to call what
we have lying it seems that that's kind
of a term that no longer applies because
after all that's only by reference to
something that we don't believe we have
anymore
so I think that he would say yeah if we
if we give
this dishonest pose of having this kind
of truth then the result isn't
everybody's a liar or only in a playful
way but the fact we're on an even
playing field and that's what we should
have acknowledged to begin with but I
think he thinks that certain poses can
be lies and the pose of having what he
thinks clearly we don't have that would
be something he would find deceptive
yeah well I I mean the way I was using
experience was closer to what you view
as the effective charge but but not not
without the the thought content that
goes with it so it's a very heavy on the
cognitive side of experience I think a
lot of times experience in Nietzsche I
think there is a lot of emphasis on
experience in Nietzsche in part because
so much of philosophy or knowledge tends
to focus on what he calls concept
mummies and it's sort of like as soon as
we get the concept down we're done and
that from his point of view is I mean
that's that's no end at all I mean
that's not an end and it's not a goal
and
it doesn't really do anything for us so
I think he's much more interested in
philosophy that relates to our ongoing
experience and he thinks that's very
difficult to do in some ways it's easier
to say well this is I mean assuming you
think you've got the truth building up
the conceptual structure he doesn't see
it so difficult but somehow being honest
to the ongoing vicissitudes of our
experience that's really the challenge
and he thinks that's what we need
especially if we're operating in a
context where god is dead we're
operating on this plane rather than
trying to see everything in terms of
some other world where there's a
symbolic significance or some kind of
significance that's more important than
the significance we give it here if what
wisdom philosophy life is about is
what's going on here then philosophy
better reflect that so that that's where
I'd see that but surely you know like
what you gained over time in terms of
knowledge would be part of that so I
wouldn't see that two poles is so far
apart yes oh yeah yeah I think I think
on the latter point I mean it may be
true that there are a lot of styles that
Picasso had command of but still looking
at Picasso's is there's something
distinctively Picasso about them and so
I think I mean it depends on it
how fine-tuned you want to call the
style and Nietzsche himself is very
interested in the possibility of giving
style to our character which I think he
sees as an ongoing process that would
involve reflecting changes but still
really pulling all of our all of the
elements of our our person and our
biography together in some way I think
is part of what he has in mind and I
think that his notion of a thought
coming when it will not when I will is
not unlike the Buddhist notion you're
talking about at all
I mean I suspect he would he would talk
about unconscious I mean to read him
back through Freud probably Freud's
notion of unconscious drives since
Nietzsche says we have lots of drives
many of which are unconscious is maybe
the way he would go with that I don't
know that he would see them as coming
from elsewhere but then I don't know
where the Tibetan Buddhists think the
thoughts come from either
yes exactly Yeah right right yes exactly
yeah in fact I had intended to mention
the aphorism as among the kinds of
stylistic devices that he inclines
toward and I think one of the reasons is
because as soon as you read one of his
aphorisms especially if it's a
particularly pithy one like out of life
school of war what does not kill me
makes me stronger people may think they
know what that means but if you start
thinking about it especially with the
preface it seems that there are a lot of
things that that might mean and I think
that that launching this whole project
of thinking about things in this general
direction and enriching our thought by
having more thoughts about it as is what
he's on to and precisely by producing an
aphorism which doesn't spell it out at
all that leaves open lots of different
ways of doing that that's oh sorry
I suppose some of the French Everest
might strike him as operating along the
lines that he thinks are worth
cultivating I I don't know I mean
there's certainly philosophers he
praises for different purposes but his
indictment of philosophers as assuming
this dogmatic pose does seem to be
pretty general most of the time yeah yes
yeah I think that's a great question and
actually I think in some ways the very
fact that I think he's he doesn't have
any kind of real justification for
saying well this is how it went as
opposed to that and he almost insists
that he can't have that because after
all the way things are used now it
doesn't mean that's how they started out
being used and they might be useful now
even though they had a very different
use of some other time but I think I
think the way he makes his case and he
does admit it to polemic so he is
suggesting it's going to be a lot of
heavy rhetoric is to actually get us to
indict ourselves so if we see something
in this that fits maybe it's worth
thinking about some more I mean I think
that's it well it is a trick it's a
trick but I think it's one that he
thinks might be useful I mean I think he
expects that it will be to a lot of
people but yeah it's not it's not what
you would expect in science certainly
yes
than it is to attract but it's it's much
more of a kind of negative about
peaches' desire to or imagine aspiration
to a and what you described seems to
resonate with that pretty strongly that
here were put in the situation we're
faced with quite abrasive views were put
in uncomfortable situations and were
forced into the position of a
philosopher in another way
Nietzsche gives us this extremely
variety it's very heterogeneous style
and and we are sort of exactly yeah
which puts us in the position of a I
think that's that's a very important
point I think that he does very much
leave it to the reader to decide what of
this is important and in what order me
goes on and on about rank ordering of
things and sometimes he's talking about
some people having a higher perspective
than other people and you know he's
quite happy to talk about people in that
light but he also talks about rank
ordering of laughter maybe that's
another vision of people with different
perspectives I think the idea though of
figuring out what's important is
something that he doesn't see it as his
place necessarily to to insist upon I
mean not that he doesn't have his own
views that he makes in some cases
abundantly clear but he has a very
interesting line in Zarathustra just in
the middle of a description of something
going on he says and as Zarathustra as
proverb has it
one thing is more important than another
well yes but which what is it and that's
that's what he I think he has to offer
you figure it out
Oh certainly
I mean Plato is I mean Plato is a flawed
- reloads - he sort of I mean Plato's
both his model and one of his worst
enemies and part of it is that Plato is
a dogmatist of the worst sort in fact he
even has a little vignette where he has
kind of Lampoon's Plato by saying I
Plato
and the truth the suggestion being that
of course Plato has this very amazing
vision that everyone would like you know
like to follow if you are entranced by
what Plato has to offer so yeah I think
that is that that is what he has in mind
often times when he's making an allusion
to Plato but besides the emotion I think
there's also the sense in which he
thinks that there's just out-and-out
presentation of things that are untrue
in any of the poet's and that just
reinforces the tendency of people to
rely on things that they don't know
themselves but they just I mean it's
it's the worst the worst case scenario
of people simply accepting things
because they're told it and poets say
things in such a nice way that people
especially want to repeat it Plato
himself would have the tendency
certainly Aristotle does it and
Nietzsche himself too for that matter
but with Plato it's very important that
we distinguish between what's appealing
and sounds good and has come to us from
someone else offering an authoritative
sounding of
piñon and something that we actually
know so I think that Nietzsche's trying
to play with that a bit too